from the most intense and dramatic
moments to the lines that keep us
laughing improv has been key to bringing
euphoria to the screen actors were
shocked and terrified while others were
in stitches getting through the
improvised dialogue we are taking a look
at how some of the best improvised
scenes in the hbo hit came to life
what are you doing
number one if we know anything by now
it's that nate and maddie probably
shouldn't be together in their tense and
dramatic scene featuring a twisted game
of russian roulette the choreography was
precise and planned but that didn't mean
everything played out as expected the
scene wasn't even really discussed
before they dove right into filming
levinson would find inspiration in the
moment and throw out suggestions while
demi and lordy work together to improv
and experiment with how their characters
behaved with each other we're not too
surprised that this was the hardest
scene alexa demi had to shoot she
couldn't escape the tense feelings of
her character because she tried to stay
in the scene while they were working
this test of endurance was made even
more intense since they filmed the scene
for a full two days and on the euphoria
set those days are usually well over 12
hours each okay this is it people
in show time let's go number two you've
never seen a high school drama
production quite like this mod apatow
was a theater kid in high school and all
that realness was brought to the seventh
episode of the second season lexi's
aggressive and kind of tyrannical
behavior backstage was easy for the
actress to tap into since it was loosely
based on her own high school experience
mick mick
a blind three-year-old could do a better
job than you levinson and apatow had had
a lot of talks about that experience so
levinson knew he could trust the actress
to nail the part and no surprise she did
i love the theater
number three it wasn't going to be a
pretty one
we thought the fight between roo and her
mom in the first season was bad but the
three-way argument between rue leslie
and gia brought the drama to new heights
the cruel words exchanged and physical
outbursts were almost entirely
improvised what we got in the show was a
totally authentic argument since none of
them knew what was coming i thought it
wasn't a good idea
let me handle this with these three
actors knowing each other so well and
having genuine love and care for each
other they were able to feel safe enough
to really go through all that all out
and surprise each other while filming
preparing to film this sequence was
tough enough without knowing what to
expect but knowing just how brutal
moments are in the series nika kings and
diana storm reed all did some mental
prep to make sure they could take proper
care of themselves emotionally on the
day
i'm so i'm sorry i didn't mean to scare
you
number four it's her kid but she can
drive her crazy the mothers in the
second season have a rough go and from
what we've seen being cassie's mom can
be a real struggle cassie please just a
little bit of peace please
so much so that the actress who plays
her ilana oobach actually wound up
cursing excessively while the two were
fighting about cassie's sleeping with
nate with this kind of drama around who
can blame her she even said you know
sydney brings it out in me she's in
character the whole time and it gets
rather scary because it's so real there
was a bit more to it though the actress
was reminded of the feistiness within
her own family dynamic when she was
growing up her mother was actually the
one who used to whip out that line about
someone needing an exorcism all the time
oh she needs a [ __ ] exorcism you
gotta work with what you know number
five who doesn't love a confession style
monologue we are here for it mod apatow
brings the euphoria magic in her
behind-the-scenes style chat about her
play and what's more is this sequence
was actually improvised by apatow and
sam levinson on set apatow didn't even
have a chance to prepare anything
because levinson didn't let her in on
what was actually happening until the
day of since they'd worked together
before the director worried that letting
mod in on what they were going to shoot
would make her freak out so he just
opted to surprise her with the scene and
work alongside her until they got what
they needed lots of laughs were had by
the casting crew as they sat filming
together while levinson showed at random
lines at apatow to say while the cameras
were rolling number six it's her first
mainstream role but she's no newbie in
fact chloe cherry is a bit of an improv
expert she learned how to do improv when
she was younger but the hobby turned out
to come in very handy when she found
herself on set cherie was the one
responsible for whipping out some of her
most memorable moments in the series the
always collaborative sam levinson even
directed the actress to just go wild
with her dialogue and thanks to that
cherry spat out some incredibly funny
lines many of which did indeed make the
cut the actress has admitted there was
plenty more improv especially between
herself and zendaya but it never wound
up being seen by audiences for the fae
actress just the fact that her words
have been bringing audiences a lot of
laughs has been a real highlight and a
major point of joy
good morning
number seven on the euphoria set it's
best to learn to expect anything minka
kelly showed up to set for her first day
and was immediately caught off guard the
sensual scene that sees maddie unzipping
her characters dress for her is
suggestive but the original plan was for
that dress to drop to the floor kelly
didn't actually know very much about her
character at this point or what they
were even trying to do with the scene so
it felt like a shocking way to start her
job as a guest on a show quickly enough
they changed the scene so the dress
didn't drop and even with the last
minute change they managed to capture
exactly what they needed
[Music]
number eight why act it when you can
live it barbie was all for new
experiences so she figured she might as
well have one in front of the entire
casting crew while the cameras were
rolling why would she put herself
through this seemingly awkward situation
the cat actress wanted to give as
genuine a reaction as she could so why
not try for a real one the shock of what
popped up on cat's screen was really
well captured in the awkward but totally
honest laughter that ensued it was an
intense and kind of strange improv but
in the end it was a moving experience
for barbie while what she saw looked
very real it was in fact just a very
realistic looking prosthetic that was
actually used
[Music]
number nine the boundaries were
definitely pushed one of the most brutal
fights in the first season was thanks to
some epic and painful improv from
zendaya and nika king thank goodness
these two actors are close and have such
deep love and respect for each other
because they go hard all that was
written in the script was rue and her
mom have a fight but those simple
directions turned into this it was all
or nothing
just go as hard as you want to go if she
goes hard you go harder is what levinson
told them to do and they did the
breaking point that stopped everyone in
their tracks was when zendaya started
going at nika with a broken piece of
glass literally running the camera
person into the wall the experience of
it was draining for the actors the crew
on set and levinson who actually had to
leave the room and take some time to
decompress solo after witnessing the
cruelly honest portrayal of what it can
be like for an addict and their family
how many times do i have to tell you
that we're not back together
right you just hung out and talked about
love
number 10 why go home when you can go
big one of nate and cassie's many fights
was a whole lot shorter to begin with
when nate goes at cassie for being a bad
friend for sleeping with her best
friend's boyfriend the two are actually
just supposed to argue for a bit and
then call it a night if you're a sweet
person you wouldn't have your best
friend's boyfriend knowing each other
and the storylines they've been working
with allordy and sweeney felt like their
fight could be much bigger and presented
an opportunity to really push boundaries
and levinson is always up for some
improv right then and there levinson
whipped together five pages worth of
dialogue and they went to filming
immediately
i love you
number eleven adding stuff late almost
always pays off when the team was
filming rue and ali having their
one-on-one special last-minute changes
were the name of the game coleman loved
the dialogue as written but levinson
didn't hesitate to bring lines to the
scene including ruse
i
near the end of the episode this moment
in the conversation was key for the
creator who wanted to make sure that
neither character was let off the hook
number 12. she knows how to work it cat
seems totally confident and in her
element when she's deep in her camming
adventures but much of what we saw
wasn't actually written in the first
place barbie was going take by take
bringing new ideas in during her camming
scenes throughout and having genuine
reactions to what she was experiencing
it's one of those things you can write
but you also don't really know the
reaction thank goodness she went for it
because some absolute gems came from
this improv including the line are you
crying now that one left all of us in
stitches
number 13 let's dive into the mind of
jewels
we're all about the anime references
scattered throughout the series and most
of them came to be because hunter
schaefer was a fan of anime herself
jules mentioning she watched madoka
magica was courtesy of the actress
herself are we gonna do some homework
bench watch some madoka magica the fact
that jules's style is so anime-like
anyway made it the perfect improv
reference lucky for schaefer who adored
all these outfits but then again who
didn't
number 14. any and all ideas are welcome
with the euphoria team since sam
levinson is so open to having the cast
collaborate with him on their characters
you throw out a line and then an actor
runs with that idea and three other
lines come out that are just a hilarious
train of thought since these actors know
their characters so well and have
offered so much input already they were
able to stop if a line didn't feel right
levinson really let the actors take the
reins allowing them to bring these
characters to life with their own
uniqueness
number 15. how many lines have we never
heard from euphoria the series creator
would come up with alt lines on the spot
simply shouting them out at cast members
while the cameras were rolling with one
new different line came a whole lot more
as the actors would rip off of whatever
they were given bringing more authentic
and solid choices to the editing table
levinson was very vocal on set there's
no doubt about it most of the dailies of
euphoria are just me yelling out lines
off-camera and then seeing what happens
euphoria truly is the result of a
tight-knit ensemble working together
these improvised scenes brought
heightened drama heartbreaking moments
and some seriously funny lines the show
is definitely better for them
which improv moment was your favorite